have you ever wondered how much power
the Queen actually had if you Google it
you'll read that oh the royal family is
just a ceremonial position it's just for
tradition they don't have any actual
power but that is just what they want
you to think see why would they try to
distract you with oh look at how this
sweet old lady smiles and waves oh look
at how pretty the princess is let's
watch her wedding while they distract
you with all of that the queen and the
Royal Family actually have an insane
amount of power and an unimaginable
amount of wealth she could veto and
change any law she pleased she could
bomb other countries she can literally
get away with murder not an exaggeration
the queen had enough money in power to
make any super villain drool from the
mouth but you will never hear about any
of this because the royal family is
smart they want you to believe that it's
all ceremonial while in the background
they abuse their power and have been
involved in all sorts of corruption
subscribe for part two to find out how